the republican-led effort to tighten
state voting laws is getting a burst of
support
from former president donald trump he
has taken a phrase used by democrats to
describe
his phony claim that the 2020 election
was stolen
and he's taking aim again at a
high-ranking member of his own party
ed o'keefe is in washington for us ed
good morning
good morning tony the former president
backed by an overwhelming number of
republicans
is pressuring gop leaders to address
their unfounded concerns about the
integrity
of last year's elections remember iowa
and georgia were among the first states
to rewrite their election laws florida's
just done so
and texas could soon be doing so too
we will win the senate former president
trump and wyoming congresswoman liz
cheney are at odds
once again in a statement monday mr
trump said the fraudulent presidential
election of 2020 will be
from this day forth known as the big lie
chaney fired back tweeting the election
was not stolen
anyone who claims it was is spreading
the big lie turning their back on the
rule of law
and poisoning our democratic system
cheney is facing primary challengers
back home and could face another
challenge to her position as the third
ranking house republican
with growing calls for her ouster from
colleagues upset she keeps fighting
publicly with the former president
recent polls show most republicans agree
with mr trump
seven in 10 don't consider president
biden the legitimate winner of last
year's election
and cbs news political analyst leslie
sanchez says those are hard numbers for
gop leaders
to ignore this is less an issue of being
loyal to trump
and more an issue of ensuring that the
republicans within their state
feel that it's a fair and legitimate
election moving forward
now texas republican legislators are
debating proposals to stop elections
officials
from sending unsolicited absentee ballot
requests
add stricter id requirements for mail
voting and make it easier for partisan
poll watchers to observe as voters
cast ballots people in america have lost
faith in their elections
and the outcome and we have to resolve
that issue but election law expert david
becker says the texas proposals would
roll back
voting rights texas was already one of
the hardest states to vote in in the
country
and they're trying to make it even
harder and last week florida republicans
passed a bill adding id requirements for
voters requesting mailed ballots
among other restrictions if lawmakers
want to increase the integrity of
american elections they should be
encouraging early
voting they should be encouraging mail
voting now some of the proposals still
up for debate in places like texas
michigan and arizona
are just that proposals still being
debated and many of the more
controversial ones could eventually get
stripped out in florida for example
they didn't outright ban the use of drop
boxes for ballots that had been up for
consideration
and in texas it's unclear if they're
going to ban the use of drive-through
voting
something that had proven quite popular
last year during the pandemic especially
in predominantly democratic areas like
houston anthony
sure did ed thank you very much ed
o'keefe